luis effet fait savoir la semaine
dernière qu'elle n'enverrait pas
d'observateurs à l'occasion des
prochaines élections législatives en
russie en cause le désaccord entre les
départs les deux parties quant au nombre
d'observateurs de l'organisation
présents sur place la correspondance à
moscou d'antoine claireaux
moscou ne voit pas d'un très bon oeil
l'intervention d'organisations
internationales dans des élections
internes à la russie le ministre des
affaires étrangères a déclaré au passage
que ces institutions comme l'eau et ses
yeux cherché à compliquer le bon
déroulement de ces élections et même au
delà de ça la décision de ne pas envoyer
d'observateurs à l'occasion de ce
scrutin ouvrirait la voie à une non
reconnaissance des résultats nous savons
que d'autres mesures sont également en
cours d'élaboration notamment que les
pays occidentaux veulent préparer à
l'avance le terrain pour tenter de
remettre en question les résultats de
nos élections nous suivons cela bien sûr
et nous allons en tirer les conclusions
appropriées et prendre les mesures
appropriées
sergey lavrov au final qualifié d'
inacceptable la décision de löw essai de
n'envoyer aucun observateur sur place et
ce à moins de six semaines du début de
cette élection les autorités russes
suivront donc de très près les
déclarations de ces organisations à
l'issue de cette élection pour rappel du
17 au 19 septembre les citoyens russes
vont renouveler les 450 députés de la
douma la chambre basse du parlement